You're,
you're an admirer of Eric Norman and off
Carl Young.
Yeah.
That's the human connection is really
interesting because I think he's a
bloody genius.
I really liked the great mother is a
great book and it really a great
warning.
That book and also the origins and
history of consciousness is influential
book.
Yeah.
That's so interesting.
I read an essay that you wrote,
I don't remember when it was at the Nyu.
Yes,
yes.
It's always been staggering to me that
that book hasn't had the impact that it
should have had.
I mean young himself in the preface to
that book wrote that that was the book
that he wished that he would have
written.
It's very much associated with young
symbols of transformation and it was a
major influence on my book,
maps of meaning,
which was an attempt to outline the
universal archetypes that are portrayed
in the kind of religious structures that
you,
that you put forward,
but the thing that I really see
happening,
and you can tell me what you think about
this and in Norman's book consciousness,
which is masculine symbolically
masculine for a variety of reasons,
is is viewed as rising up against the
countervailing force of tragedy from an
underlying feminine symbolically
feminine unconsciousness.
Right?
And it's something that can always be
pulled back into that unconsciousness.
That would be the microcosm of.
That would be the Freudian eatable
mother femineity old dynamic where the
mother was so over protective and all
encompassing that she interferes with
the development of the competence not
only of her sons,
but also of her daughters,
of her children in general.
And it seems to me that that's the
dynamic that's being played out in our
society right now is that there's this
and it's.
It's related in some way that I don't
understand to this,
to this insistence that all forms of
masculine and authority or nothing by
tyrannical power.
So the symbolic representation is
tyrannical father with no appreciation
for the benevolent father and benevolent
mother with no appreciation whatsoever
for the tyrannical mother.
Right?
And that's that.
And because I thought of videology as
fragmentary mythologies,
that's where they get their archetypal
in psychological power,
right?
And so on and balanced representation.
You have the terrible mother and the
great mother as as Norman laid out so
nicely and you have the terrible father
and the great father.
So that's the fact that culture mangles
you have to death well.
It's also promoting you and developing
you.
You have to see that as balanced and
then you have the heroic and adversarial
individual.
But in the postmodern world,
and this seems to be something that's
increasingly seeping out into the
culture at large,
you have nothing but the tyrannical
father.
Nothing but the destructive force of
masculine consciousness and nothing but
the benevolent,
benevolent great mother,
and it's an.
It's an appalling ideology and it seems
to me that it's sucking the vitality,
which is exactly what you would expect
symbolically.
It's sucking the vitality of our
culture.
You see that with the increasing
demolition of,
of young men,
um,
and not only young men in terms of their
academic performance,
which like they're falling way behind in
elementary school way behind in junior
high and bailing out of the universities
like mad.